e pronto peppe che c'è la terza volta
stavo dormendo
no no no no no no no no non esiste ma
come anche woody devo annunciare io il
decreto per ri per il natale ma perché
io ti feriscono i commenti che ti
scrivono ormai non me la sento
sinceramente di team e con quale carica
no cerca qualcun altro io col cav
buongiorno a tutti oggi vorrei esporvi
il nuovo decreto per le vacanze 2020
prima di cominciare vorrei ricordare che
i teatri e le scuole rimarranno chiuse
per sempre al fine di crescere i nostri
figli nell'ignoranza più selvaggia
stiamo facendo grandi sforzi per aiutare
tutte le persone in difficoltà tramite
degli investimenti a fondo perduto nel
senso proprio che ne abbiamo persi
non avevo proprio idea di dove siano
finiti però fino ad allora potrete
comunque utilizzare gli indennizzi nella
cassa integrazione che gli arriveranno
insieme alla lettera di ammissione alla
scuola di magia e stregoneria di
hogwarts rimane obbligatorio l'uso della
mascherina nei luoghi pubblici per
strada nei balconi tranne nei casi in
cui si riesca a trattenere il respiro a
sufficienza
ricordiamo che tutte le persone fatte
capaci di rimanere in apnea dalle sei
ore in su potranno girare comodamente
avviso scoperto quest'anno comunque
vogliamo evitare qualsiasi tipo di
allarmismi il natale si festeggerà la
nostra economia non può permettersi di
fermarsi in questo momento storico ecco
perché sebbene le attività commerciali
continueranno a dover rispettare gli
orari di apertura e chiusura che vanno
dal sol bemolle alle marche caltagirone
abbiamo deciso di permettere ai
meccanici di rimanere aperti
ricordiamo che continua a essere
severamente vietato l'uso delle
automobili pena mi fai perché do cazzo
vai ci stiamo impegnando al fine di
creare un clima sereno per tutte quante
le famiglie che si apprestano a
festeggiare il natale e la cena della
vigilia infatti abbiamo deciso di fare
una piccola eccezione permettendo a
tutte le persone risultate positive al
tampone negli ultimi sette mesi di
passare la serata insieme al proprio
specchio preferito a tutti negativi da
meno di cinque mesi a questa parte
invece dovranno moltiplicare il quadrato
costruito sul catetere diviso
l'ipotenusa del vostro codice fiscale
qualora e dico solo qualora il risultato
dovesse essere un numero tra 12 e jack
di coppe si prega di contattare l'asl di
riferimento al fine di non ricevere
risposta alcuna ogni famiglia verrà dato
insieme a un panettone un tampone in
omaggio e un termometro da cucina con il
quale misurare le temperature delle
vostre pietanze qualora queste dovessero
superare i 37,5 gradi significherà che
siete stati a contatto con pietanze
positive dovrete sottoporvi una
quarantena cautelativa fino a che non si
troverà una cura alla morte il cenone
non sarà possibile trascorrere un
ristorante a meno che non abbiate soli
in compagnia del cartonato di un vostro
parente o di un peluche adeguatamente
sterilità
inoltre non è più consentito ordinare
cibo da asporto dopo mezzogiorno e prima
delle 11 e 40 di mattina infine ci
teniamo a ribadire che la spesa online è
permessa solo per beni di primissima
necessità quali gallette di mais acqua
distillata e surimi per quest'ultimo
punto non esiste una vera e propria
spiegazione che ci faceva ridere
aggiungervi qualche caso è quindi così
abbiamo deciso di metter cielo comunque
i botti di capodanno importantissimo
saranno sostituiti con le urla di dolore
di tutte le persone che proveranno a
sottoporsi da sole al tampone in omaggio
col pandoro e mezzi pubblici inoltre
saranno ancora disponibili ma potranno
ospitare un numero limitato di persone
pari a 300 perché secondo me il film
molto bello e a partire dalle ore smash
del 18 dicembre partirà il coprifuoco
casalingo vi spiego subito in cosa
consiste praticamente dalle 18 alle 7
della vigilia non potrete più usare il
bagno sarà dunque possibile cag harvey
in mano e riporre le fece all'interno
del vostro forno della lavastoviglie la
cucina sarà accessibile a ogni luna
piena il resto del tempo potrete
utilizzarla solo d'asporto ecco perché
invitiamo che bisogno a spostare il
frigo in balcone fatelo subito perché
non sappiamo quando potrete entrarci
nuovamente in contatto e infine sarà
possibile mettersi a letto solamente con
prenotazione on line due tamponi nelle
narici maschera boccaglio e un collarino
di conchiglia ci rendiamo conto degli
sforzi enormi che vi abbiamo chiesto e
che continuiamo a chiedervi ogni giorno
ecco perché quest'anno abbiamo deciso di
permettere lo scambio di regali di
persona e non attraverso un vetro
antiproiettile vestiti da palombari come
era stato suggerito la settimana scorsa
unica prerogativa i doni non devono
essere vuoti ma se i nostri calcoli sono
esatti questo natale dovreste trovarvi
tutti con le pezze al culo quindi il
problema non si pone anzi nel
malaugurato caso in cui qualcuno di voi
riesca ancora a campare e vi chiediamo
di compilare il prima possibile il form
presente nell'info box qui sotto al fine
di garantirvi una rapina entro dieci
giorni dall'invio importantissimo il
presepe ora per quanto sconsigliatissimo
se sentite il bisogno di celebrare il
folklore natalizio creando assembramenti
sappiate che il numero massimo di
quindi da poter inserire è di 6 ognuna
di queste a debita distanza con guanti
mascherina tranne gesù che essendo
bambini non ancora l'obbligo di
indossarla nella grotta potrà esserci
solo in un nucleo familiare del messia
quindi maria e gesù il bue l'asinello
potranno aiutare solo se negativi al
tampone molecolare per quanto riguarda
gli alberi di natale sarà consentito
montargli all'interno delle palestre che
comunque rimarranno chiuse fino a data
da destinarsi vi consigliamo quindi di
montare delle webcam
all'interno di questi luoghi in modo da
poterli osservare da remoto ora per
tutte le persone che non hanno più una
casa
ci stiamo impegnando affinché siate
sempre di più desideriamo comunque darvi
la possibilità di adottare un albero ne
stiamo importando 20.000 dall'amazzonia
per aiutare l'economia del sud america
dopo il terribile incendio per chiunque
lo desiderasse potrete ricevere al costo
di 9,99 euro un'urna funeraria ripiena
di cenere per tutto il resto ci stiamo
impegnando al fine di riportare le cose
alla normalità a partire dal prossimo
natale 2032
fino ad allora vi consigliamo se mai
doveste beccare babbo natale che esce
dal vostro cammino leggo testuali parole
di pestarlo a sangue rapinarlo di
portafogli chiavi della slitta regali ed
eventuali beni di prima necessità il
decreto lo permette vi consigliamo
inoltre di infilarlo nel portabagagli
della vostra macchina fargli un tampone
è un sierologico a forza perché qualora
dovesse risultare positivo potrebbero
scattare i termini di una denuncia il
mio augurio a tutti voi e che possiate
alla luce di quest'ultimo decreto
passare natale sereno
vi ricordiamo inoltre che la
programmazione del film natalizie
rimarrà la stessa con qualche piccola
modifica per rendere più sopportabile a
questo momento di difficoltà alle 20 e
30 su rai 1 verrà trasmesso in prima
serata una poltrona per uno con eddie
murphy e basta a seguire mamma ho perso
il referto ghost e edward mani ingegni
date detto questo non mi resta che
augurarvi
buon natale e un felice anno nuovo nella
speranza che questa situazione possa
finire il prima possibile
giuseppe
vabbè giusta io lo fa cioè ho letto io
ho letto quello che devo leggere
comunque alla fine è completo e
comprensibile chiaro chiaro